gardez la franche au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en apprennent
à tricoter d'accord là-dessus à votre
place je la ramène un peu moins mais si
vous ne réussissez pas c'est qu'il vous
manque qu'une seule chose un tout petit
détail le tronc fais les valises à paris
qu'est ce qu'il lui arrive à la baisse
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'inattendu
trente ans après edith cresson elisabeth
bornes devient donc la deuxième chef du
gouvernement de l'histoire mais au fait
dit-on madame le ministre ou madame la
ministre
hockey
désespéré d'autant plus volontiers que
[Musique]
l'on se dressera mois en respectant mon
sexe et ma féminité
en dix ans madame la ministre
et en parlant de la représentante du
gouvernement
et justement madame la ministre est avec
nous pour nous aider à bien comprendre
l'importance de cette nomination bonjour
elisabeth guigou vous avez été ministre
de la justice ministre de l'emploi c'est
d'ailleurs vous que l'on voit sur ces
archives vous avez quels souvenirs de
cette période de cette journée nous
étions sept femmes dans le gouvernement
jospin nous nous étions promise à tout
de faire bloc si jamais il y avait dans
l'assemblée nationale
des propos sexistes ou insultant
vis-à-vis de l'une d'entre nous avec
nous partirions ensemble c'était
important de marquer qu'il y avait des
choses qu'on ne supporterait plus voilà
en tout cas madame le ou la ministre
camille d'auxerre il n'y a pas de débat
cette semaine pour elisabeth bordeaux
n'ont pas de débat c'est madame la
première ministre et aux petites filles
elle a passé un message je ne peux pas
m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée pour la
première femme qui a occupé ses
fonctions
edith cresson et peut-être je voudrais
dédier cette nomination à toutes les
petites filles en leur disant aller au
bout de vos rêves
c'est formidable parce que c'est vrai
quand même qu'on a encore encore
maintenant même si les progrès faits on
a encore des pesanteurs culturelles et
sociales qui assigne les filles à
certaines choses eric zemmour a dit il
ya quelques jours
première ministre c'est moche vous lui
répondez quoi il est resté bloqué dans
les années 90 non mais c'est lui qui est
moche tout prévu
alors qu'amy en tout cas sous la vème
république le pouvoir politique a été
conjugué très souvent au masculin oui
presque toujours au masculin c'était une
affaire d'hommes sous de gaulle et
pompidou alors il ya eu quelques femmes
et elle était uniquement des secrétaires
d'état aucune ministre de plein exercice
si je vous dis nafissa 6 carats est ce
que ça vous dit quelque chose puisque
vous en souvenez bien fut fêté la
première sous la vème république en
1959 à devenir secrétaire d'état elle
était en charge des questions sociales
en algérie alors on va voir la photo du
l'image du gouvernement de l'époque elle
est au second rang voilà elle est cachée
est juste là on pense à l'image est un
peu flou mais c'est pour vous donner une
idée d'autres femmes arrive ensuite dans
l'histoire marie-madeleine dinesh voici
la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'éducation nationale puis suzanne plouc
est à droite à l'image qui est qui la
remplace au secrétariat également chargé
de l'éducation l'éducation la santé bon
c'est assez convenu on donne aux femmes
des responsabilités de femmes ben on
leur donne des responsabilités dans les
domaines où on reconnaît qu'elle est
longue on admet mettant ce qu'elles ont
une compétence et à dire tous les
domaines sociaux les domaines où mattern
ou on l'est du coup alors bon c'est un
progrès des gars parce que
je mets mais c'est quelque chose qui va
évoluer très très lentement il ya un
tournant quand même c'est en 1974 avec
avec l'élection de valéry giscard
d'estaing qui fait des choix dans ce qui
fait des choix mais parce qu'il se veut
président moderne alors il veut des
femmes au gouvernement c'est chose faite
simone veil évidemment devient la
première femme
ministre de plein exercice
on voit également françoise giroud qui
est secrétaire d'état à la condition
féminine et alice saunier sight ministre
des universités alors forcément les
médias s'intéressent à ce changement à
cette féminisation des femmes au
gouvernement mais pourquoi donc
pourquoi tant de femmes pourquoi ce goût
pour les femmes la politique parce que
là aussi c'est une évolution
contemporaine et une évolution dans
laquelle la france est à l'avant garde
avec désormais cinq femmes gouvernement
et deux d'entre elles ayant des
responsabilités de gestion considérable
d'une part madame veille avec sa
responsabilité en ce qui concerne le
grand domaine de la santé et d'autre
part madame saunier séité avec le très
grand domaine des universités qu'elle
aura à gérer et trois secrétaires d'état
nous serons le gouvernement du monde
dans lequel la participation féminine
sera la plus belle du monde et d'autre
part le choix à ses femmes a été fait
comme s'il s'agissait de choisir des
hommes c'est à dire en fonction de leurs
capacités de leurs compétences
est-ce que ça ça relève de la part de
valéry giscard d'estaing d'un coup de
com ou est ce que vous pensez qu'ils
croyaient vraiment à la place des femmes
au sein d'un gouvernement je crois que
ça reflète l'évolution de la société moi
j'ai pas voté jusqu'à 174 je reconnais
qu'il a fait faire un progrès
il ya ils se sont aperçus dans les
milieux politiques les femmes votaient
et qu'elle ne votez pas comme on disait
au 10ème siècle uniquement sur l'
influence de la calotte pour les
suffragettes c'était ça on voulait pas
donner le droit de vote parce qu'on
pensait qu'elle était soumise au diktat
de l'église qui était très conservatrice
mais ça c'est ça veut dire que quand il
ya une impulsion une impulsion politique
une pulsion public il se passe des
choses et tout il faut reconnaître que
tous les présidents de la république
successifs ont eu à coeur de faire ce
alors pour des raisons électorales
certainement pour des seins quand même
ils avaient à coeur d'épouser les
évolutions de la société mais mais les
femmes à cette époque elles sont tout de
même ramené un statut d'alibi de quotas
c'est toujours louche de voir arriver
une femme simone veil on avait
conscience bien que ministre de la santé
mais a quand même accepté le poste
mai 1974 jacques chirac songe à confier
un portefeuille à simone veil il faut
féminiser le gouvernement est libéralisé
en ce sens simone veil est un beau
n'être
simone veil est lucide elle a écrit en
73 que les femmes sont présentes au
gouvernement qu'au titre du cas d'espèce
et au parlement à dose homéopathique
vous avez accepté d'être ministre mais
qu'y at il dans ce oui
la curiosité d'abord un peu de vanité
aussi sûrement
et puis oui l'envi de
envie d'être efficace de se dire que
pendant des années on a eu on a fait
quelques fois que certaines choses ne
soient pas faites et
de se dire qu'on aura
peut-être la possibilité d'infléchir
certaines actions
on est tenté d'accepter la curiosité la
vanité l'envi d'infléchir qu'est ce qui
vous a donné à voulant vie de dire oui
je t'ai pas vous mettez pas programmé
pour une carrière politique et que
j'étais plutôt technocrates voilà et
puis c'est de travailler à l'elysée avec
le président mitterrand
kingking voilà qui met quand il m'a
offert une chance formidable j'ai été
bombardé ministre je demander d'ailleurs
au président mitterrand 24 heures pour
réfléchir parce que j'avais conscience
que il fallait je voulais être élu ici
j'étais ministre donc c'était une autre
vie quoi vous aviez peur de quoi
cette réflexion séchage et j'avais peur
d'être de passer dans la lumière avec
tout ce qui s'ensuit c'est à dire les
attaques d'ailleurs ça n'a pas manqué
donc donc voilà alors et notamment les
attaques qui visent les femmes pour une
femme c'est toujours envie de vente
toujours plus quoi il faut vraiment
prouver à chaque instant qu'on n'ait pas
simplement une image voilà tout à
l'heure vous nous avez
avoir applaudi en tout cas avoir
apprécié le choix de valéry giscard
d'estaing même si vous n'aviez pas voté
pour lui en 74 lorsqu'il a nommé
plusieurs femmes au gouvernement la
gauche vous nous en parler a poussé le
curseur encore un petit peu plus loin
camille avec absolument mais vous l'avez
vécu d'ailleurs ils avaient des goûts
puisque vous voyez vous étiez ministre
dans le premier gouvernement dirigé par
cette femme edith cresson françois
mitterrand la nomme en 1991 alors des
réactions à l'époque il y en a eu des
tonnes j'en ai choisi une elle est très
courte mais je pense qu'elle est
révélatrice de ce que pensent et
beaucoup d'hommes politiques à l'époque
vraiment on est dans un système
incroyablement monarchie regardez le
parcours de madame de pompadour regardez
le parcours d'edith cresson il ya un
parallélisme certains voient là une
femme nommée à ce poste de premier
ministre c'est la favorite c'est la
pompadour
c'était elle a subi édite des attaques
et monde elle l'a dit d'ailleurs
quelqu'un je me souviens encore du
guignol des infos
c'était affreux quoi et des attaques
grossières des intérêts on ne
supporterait plus ça aujourd'hui mais
j'en parle bien avec elle bien sûr mais
évidemment à l'époque et c'était s'était
enfin on était endetté
mais c'était au delà d'être d'être
choqués quoi je prends ce serait jamais
comporté comme ça avec un homme jamais
jamais jamais encore aujourd'hui je
crois faut montrer ça je vous montrais
pour que on dise plus jamais ça
camille jacques chirac arrive donc après
après françois mitterrand et avec
l'ubaye et une apparente féminisation de
la scène gouvernementale évidemment et
avec les fameuses jupette le
gouvernement d'alain juppé 12 femmes qui
sont nommés dont quatre ministres alors
vous voyez elle arrive là dans aller
dans la cour de l'elysée à l'époque dans
les commentaires des journalistes
le seul détail qui compte finalement
c'est la couleur de leurs tailleurs
est-ce que vous aussi en tant que femme
politique vous avez subi c'est
commentaires sur vos vêtements est ce
que vous avez dû changer est ce que ça
vous a heurté
évidemment parce que on ne regarde que
ça où on ne commente que ça pour les
femmes comment est-ce qu'on est habillé
est ce qu'on est trop gros trop grosses
ou trop maigre ou bon pour avoir la paix
moi j'ai surtout porter des pantalons
parce que quand vous êtes sur une
estrade au moins se pratique en tout cas
ce gouvernement des jupettes n'a pas
fait long feu quelques mois six mois et
quand il a fallu annoncer le remaniement
le départ de toutes ses fans et bien
vous allez voir il ya un petit ton un
peu ironique un petit sourire en coin de
la part du présentateur
les femmes ont donc été les principales
victimes du remaniement ministériel
puisqu'elles sont huit sur les treize
sortant est certain aujourd'hui
d'ironiser elles n'ont servi que de
gadgets l'espace de six mois il faisait
beau ce matin de mai sur le perron de
l'elysée douze femmes ministres ou
secrétaires d'état prenaient leur
service il faisait gris voire froid ce
matin et on ne compte plus que quatre
femmes rescapées c'est un coup dur porté
à la politique c'est vrai que huit jupe
est qui et qui s'en vantant en même
temps ça fait beaucoup et nous qui
venons d'installer l'observatoire de la
parité pour que les femmes accèdent à la
politique à égalité avec les hommes nous
aurons encore beaucoup de chemin
beaucoup de travail à faire ensemble
pour y parvenir en cas de crise quand on
recentre un petit peu les
responsabilités trop souvent les comptes
le simple terme jupette finalement c'est
ça n'est pas la cause
des femmes évidemment mais nous les
fables de gauche où nous étions dans
l'opposition nous nous étions concertée
et nous avons publié un aurait action en
disant mais c'est pas possible le croire
pourquoi s'il fallait remanier le
gouvernement pourquoi simplement les
femmes le monde de la politique il est
violent avec les femmes
on l'aperçoit et vous aviez écrit un
livre d'ailleurs sur le fait d'être
femme en politique en 1997 vous êtes sur
le plateau d' anne sinclair sur 7 sur 7
avec simone veil on regarde vous dit à
partir d'octobre 90 quand j'entrais au
gouvernement là j'allais vraiment
découvrir ce que la politique réservé
aux femmes et vous dites du bizutage au
traitement ignoble regardez par exemple
à l'idée de créer son nom mais c'est
vrai c'est un bizutage est bête et
méchant comme tous les bizutages on
s'attaque aux femmes alors pourquoi on
peut se demander et je crois que c'est
parce que au fond les femmes qui pénètre
en politique pénètre sur un territoire
interdit
encore largement très très largement
masculin et qu'on leur pardonne pas
cette transgression et que l'on cherche
au fond elle est allé ramener sous les
halles est rabaissée et les juniors de
l'asc en gros que deux rôles celui de
mer et vous dit simone veil illustre
très bien ou celui de cheftaine ce qui
me frappe en ce moment par rapport à il
ya 20 ans où j'étais au gouvernement
sait combien la violence vis-à-vis des
femmes est devenue beaucoup plus grande
les femmes dans la vie politique mais
vraiment il ya une agressivité et je
crois que c'est parce que les femmes les
hommes sont plus menacés la
transgression des femmes est ce que ça a
changé aujourd'hui
ce combat toujours recommencée mais
quand même les choses ont évolué dans le
bon sens c'est à dire que j'ai quand
même le sentiment que la honte est passé
de l'autre côté quoi voilà le
politiquement correct aujourd'hui est
passé de l'autre côté donc tant mieux la
seule façon réalité de lutter contre le
sexisme compris le sexisme ordinaire et
qui continue c'est la solidarité des
femmes entre elles il fallait que les
femmes à libérer les femmes qu'on avait
mises en avant elles surtout aussi
ensuite d'autres il fallait que on est à
coeur de promouvoir d'autres femmes
parce que c'est le nombre qui changera
les choses c'est ça en tout cas vous
avez ouvert la voie à d'autres femmes at
absolument absolument début des années
2000 une autre femme que vous voyez là
qui est dans un alphajet de la
patrouille de france c'est michèle
alliot marie en l'espace de dix ans elle
va devenir mini de la défense de
l'intérieur de la justice et des
affaires étrangères pour trois d'entre
elles sera donc la première femme à
avoir ces postes michèle alliot marie
qui avant de devenir ministre donnait
déjà le ton
comment vous avez trouvé le l'ocde dit
qu'est ce que vous avez mais sa veste
pied de poule et sa façon de retrousser
les manches avant d'attaquer écoutez moi
ça m'ennuie beaucoup vous me parliez de
ça parce que je crois que edith cresson
et premier ministre s est premier
ministre de mon âge je le reste les
détails vestimentaires ont pas parlé
michèle alliot marie dans les cas vérité
interrogée par france approche les alors
elle est député rpr à l'époque elle
soutient edith cresson premier ministre
de gauche est ce qu'il ya une vraie
solidarité entre femmes politiques oui
je crois qu'à des moments importants ça
existe quand même et heureusement et au
fond vous notez aussi que c'est en
raison de cette solidarité au delà des
clivages politiques qui a une continuité
malin touche et tous les présidents de
la vème république pour faire progresser
la cause des femmes plus ou moins mais
quand même et quand on a des mines
politiques publiques comme ça qui a qui
traverse les alternances quand même et
il ya des progrès depuis quelques années
la parité et réclamé dans les dents les
gouvernements est ce que c'est une bonne
chose
oui je crois je crois que je crois qu'il
faut que le gouvernement de la france
représente la société française dans
universités alors il ya la parité ça me
paraît essentiel mais il ya aussi la
diversité sociale et on a encore des
gouvernements qui sont trop homogène et
je rebondis sur ce que vous dites
puisque les dernière femme à avoir été
nommé dans ces derniers gouvernements
elles ont amené cette diversité si on
cite par exemple rachida dati rama yade
fleur pellerin ou christiane taubira
pour ne citer qu'elles voilà l ont amené
aussi ça avec elle en plus de leur
féminité autre exemple avec najat
vallaud belkacem en 2012 on est au
lendemain de sa nomination comme
ministre des droits des femmes et voilà
ce qu'on lui demande et donc c'est pas
une caution diversité du gouvernement
comme l'était rachida dati à l'époque
écoutez le gouvernement qui a formé
aujourd'hui françois hollande est aux
couleurs de la france et je pense que
c'est ce que les français attendent et
un gouvernement qui leur ressemble cela
étant c'est vrai que je n'ai jamais fait
de mes origines un étendard et je ne
compte pas le faire aujourd'hui je me
considère d'abord comme une élue de la
république française au service du
peuple français donc après la ministre
gadgets celle qui doit séduire les
électrices la femme ministre issu de la
diversité devient l'alibi diversité non
mais nadja tête une idée formidable
rachida on avait des désaccords bêtement
à la morale imprime quand même un bon
tout est donc non je crois qu'il faut
il faut savoir que tant que l'on
continuera à s'étonner par exemple
qu'une femme soit première ministre
comme c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui
eh bien les femmes subiront ce genre de
questions ça devrait même pas se poser
quoi donc voila mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut il faut des gouvernement et une
assemblée nationale et un sénat qui soit
davantage représentatifs et ça ça passe
par une diversité d'origines sociales
une diversité d'origines culturelles
voilà mais vous savez qu'on va exaucer
votre veut et on va parler de la
représentativité des députés notamment à
l'assemblée nationale mais d'abord le
zapping de l'inattendu et merci à vous
camille pour ceux d'oslo
[Musique]
les abeilles bonjourbonjour dernière
nous avons beaucoup de plaisir à vous
accueillir dans l'émission parce que
vous représentez vraiment l'avenir du
cinéma français bon ça je sais pas
aujourd'hui un peu partout en france on
se rassemblait pour la première journée
mondiale contre l'homophobie
l'occasion de rappeler que dont près de
80 pays l'homosexualité reste encore
condamnée par la loi je viendrai faire
un cadeau à thierry roland lui qui a
toujours été très gentil et très avec
mon club parce que les autoriser
vous avez à chauve couronné ici sans
tricher les cheveux sont partis sous le
sommet errait sur le côté et puis alors
notre idéal à tous c'est devenir chauffe
intégral comme notre cher ami ernst
juste avant un tête à tête de 35 minutes
dans la cour l'aîné a toujours l'oeil il
bouge son cadet mal placé pour la caméra
[Applaudissements]
après l'échangé des consentements et des
alliances le prince harry et meghan
markle ont désormais uni leur destin
bonsoir oui mais
voilà l'inattendu avec elisabeth guigou
alors dans quelques semaines vous allez
désigner celles et ceux qui vous
représenteront à l'assemblée nationale
connaissez-vous votre député je ne parle
pas de sa famille politique mais de son
métier bonjour géraldine corner davost
cela s'appelle la représentativité
sociale et c'est très important oui
parce que les députés sont souvent
accusés d'être un peu loin du peuple un
peu technocrates elisabeth guigou
forcément je parle de vous vous avez été
député près de quinze ans vous êtes
énarque ce qu'on peut appeler aussi une
technocrate est-ce que sans passer par
la case forcément vie civile est ce que
ça c'est des reproches qu'on vous a déjà
fait au sein de l'hémicycle au début oui
bien sûr évidemment aidé à mon parti
politique aussi d'ailleurs enfin est-ce
que c'est une tare d'avoir des
compétences quand même hein alors quel
est le profil des députés gerling
comment at il évolué dans le temps
ouvriers cadres ou bien agriculteurs qui
sont i oui parce qu'on a tendance à
l'oublier mais députés ce n'est pas un
métier c'est une fonction que l'on
occupe le temps d'un ou plusieurs
mandats et la représentativité sociale à
l'assemblée nationale est effectivement
pas mal évolué j'avais envie de
m'intéresser à la classe populaire et
plus particulièrement d'anglais vraiment
sur les ouvriers dans l'hémicycle où
sont ils qui sont ils on regarde 1945 la
classe populaire est bien présente à
l'assemblée nationale décidément je ne
souhaite pas apporter du nouveau au
total 65 ouvriers parmi 5 122 députés ça
restera un record
mais rapidement les ouvriers sont moins
nombreux sur les bancs de l'assemblée
pourtant en 1967 la représentativité
sociale semble est cruciale pour ce
député et je crois que le fait d'avoir
dans une assemblée des personnes
provenant d'activités de professions
différentes est extrêmement important
parce que chacun fait bénéficier les
autres de son expérience à la place des
ouvriers des fonctionnaires des cadres
et autres professions libérales
s'installe à l'assemblée de quoi
questionné un journaliste de l'humanité
vous pensez que les députés de votre
parti du dr
qui compte plus de choix son
administrateur de sociétés sont
représentatifs vraiment de la nation
dans la composition sociale la nation je
crois bien que c'est le peuple qui a élu
ses députés alors qu'il s'est pris un
directeur de société
l'ouvrier ou un fonctionnaire ça c'est
dans chaque arrondissement le choix des
électeurs
les élections s'enchaînent et la classe
populaire disparaît lentement de
l'assemblée
même dans les années 80 alors que la
gauche est au pouvoir la chute du nombre
d'ouvriers continue il ya eu un temps de
rêve du suffrage universel la
constitution d un front démocratique où
on s'est dit on va faire la promotion de
toutes les catégories au sein de l'ue et
du parlement bah il se trouve qu'il ya
pratiquement pas pratiquement pas
d'ouvriers d'employés c'est aussi un
sacré problème les raisons de ce
changement le parti communiste
s'effondre un peu plus à chaque
législative et le ps s'embourgeoise
alors quand un ouvrier fait son entrée à
l'assemblée nationale en 1997
ça devient un événement l'idée vient
surtout des gens avec qui je travaille
qui m'ont dit il faut que tu montres que
tu représentes le monde ouvrier et ça
serait bien que pour la première séance
y allant de travail bon
j'ai accédé à leur demande en 2012
retour du parti socialiste et un seul
député ouvriers sur 577
2017 sonne le glas plus aucun ouvrier
dans l'hémicycle c'est une première
depuis 1946
voilà on va pas le nier il ya un
décalage entre la représentativité
sociale de l'assemblée et celle de la
population générale oui exactement 1 0 %
d'ouvriers à l'assemblée nationale on
l'a vu en 2010 est pourtant ils
représentent 20% de la population
française est en revanche 76 % de
députées cadres ou de professions
intellectuelles alors qu'ils ne
représentent que
17,1 pour cent de la population est ce
que comme on l'a entendu dans le
reportage comme le disait roland carole
est ce que c'est un problème cette
relève d'un tati vite évidemment c'est
un problème il faudrait que dans les
partis politiques parce que c'est là
qu'est le vivier est d'abord qu'ils
soient plus attirant c'est à dire qu' il
soit plus au contact de ces populations
appliquer des formations elisabeth
guigou on va terminer cet inattendu avec
notre traditionnel pépite aller piocher
dans les archives de l'ina chaque
semaine alors elisabeth borgne a dédié
sa nomination où il avait entendu tout à
l'heure à toutes les petites filles
aller au bout de vos rêves et surtout
n'écoutez pas les les petits garçons
comme celui ci interrogé par antenne 2
dans les années 80 et coûté
politiquement série
non on a ça me plait pas les femmes
politiques sur un carnage il faut payer
verront un contrat avant le signe et
puis avant du royaume c'est bon si tout
est pourquoi tu crois que les hommes au
mieux ils réfléchissent compte ici
quelque chose
j'ose à peine vous demander votre
réaction posté à 36 ans quand même
oui mais voilà chaque femme qui a un
fils ou des fils à la responsabilité
aussi de les éduquer rien ne remplace
l'éducation des parents après l'école
pour rectifier les choses mais voilà et
donc il faut dès la toute petite enfance
voilà et moi je suis très heureux j'ai
deux petites filles elles savent que
rien ne leur sera interdit elisabeth
guigou merci en tout cas de votre
participation à cette inattendue
géraldine corner lavaud merci pour ce
dossier on se retrouve bien sûr la
semaine prochaine sur le canal 27 ans et
toute la semaine sur les réseaux sociaux
que ce soit ceux de l'ina ou ceux de
france info merci à toutes celles et
ceux qui ont préparé cette émission et
merci à vous d'être là chaque semaine
[Musique]